- Hey, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
into another edition of "Market Takes".
I know you could've been
anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me,
and I appreciate that.
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin,
reporter at "The Wall Street Journal".
This is "Market Takes".
There's a lot going on out in the world,
but we are going to tell
you the three things
you need to be watching for this week
as you look to make sense of
what's going on in the world.
So, big thing, obviously,
you've been hearing all
about it in the news,
seeing all the headlines,
that's this Debt Ceiling debate.
We're going to breakdown
what's actually happening.
Make a little sense of all this hoopla
that you're hearing out there in the news.
We are going to talk
through some important
housing reports that are
coming out this week.
We are seeing some very
significant movement
in the housing market that, I think,
bears watching out this week.
And then we are going to
get just a deluge of U.S.
Business Conditions report
from the Federal Reserve
and from others this week.
That I think is really going to
tell us some interesting things
about the state of the economy.
You're going to want to know
what to watch out for there.
Listen, let's just
really quickly step back
and talk about the Debt Ceiling.
Let's separate truth from fiction,
and a little bit of all the blase blah
that you've been hearing about
in the headlines right now.
So the Debt Ceiling,
the important thing to keep in mind
is we don't have to argue about this.
Congress doesn't have to argue about this.
This is a chosen battle.
The Debt Ceiling has been
raised 78 times since 1962;
49 of those under Republican presidents,
29 of those under Democratic presidents.
It usually happens without
a lot of back and forth.
This year we've got a standoff,
and we've got this standstill.
We are having negotiations now.
We are approaching June 1st.
That June 1st X-date
that Treasury Secretary,
Janet Yellen has said when the treasury
will start to run out of funding
and have to not pay
some of its obligations.
That's happened because we already,
essentially, hit the Debt Ceiling number.
We reached the $31.4 trillion
debt limit back in late January,
and the Treasury Department
has already been taking
extraordinary measures to keep the country
from not paying some of its obligations.
Now important to talk about,
you're hearing a lot of talk
about defaulting and default.
That doesn't mean the U.S. isn't going
to pay the interest on
the money that it owes.
It doesn't mean there's actually
going to be a default on U.S. debt.
Default, in the way that a lot
of folks have been using that term,
literally just means that some
things might not get paid.
Some social security
beneficiaries might not get paid.
Some Medicare beneficiaries,
VA veteran assistance,
things like that, or Obamacare,
things that the government
is on the hook to pay for,
that they are mandated pay for,
they might not make a payment on.
The treasury is going to
prioritize paying the debt,
because if the U.S. doesn't pay its debt,
well, that could mean a debt default,
which could mean a downgrade
of the U.S. credit limit,
which could mean that it
costs significantly more
for the U.S. to borrow,
which would kind of raise
the rates for borrowing across
the board in the economy.
That would be very bad.
The treasury is going to
do everything in its power
to avoid that which means
likely not paying back
some of these other things
rather than defaulting
or having an actual default on the debt.
So, really quickly let's
take a look at the timeline.
April 18th was tax day.
We all know that because
we had to get the taxes in.
Secretary Yellen based her estimates
of what the treasury has to pay for things
on what the tax receipts
estimates were for that.
Now CBO and treasury
are still kind of counting
some of these receipts,
but we have an idea of how much money
came in from taxes since
that April 18th number.
But no one outside of
the Treasury Department
actually knows how much money
because again they haven't told us.
This is really just an estimate.
Now the Congressional Budget
Office, the CBO has estimated,
and they've said that receipts
in April 2023 were 26% less
than the amount recorded in
the same month last year,
which means based on
the estimates they have,
they actually got less in
taxes than they expected
and less than last year.
Now we've seen that was driven
by a 36% decline in
individual income taxes.
CBO's projections show
a federal budget deficit
$100 billion more than estimated.
Basically, they got less from taxes,
largely from individuals,
and now they're saying,
"Okay, well, we've got
less money to deal with,"
so we could be actually closer
to that sort of default scenario
or not paying back certain,
or not paying for certain obligations
than that June 1st deadline even.
So, again, when we hit June,
it's likely if we don't
get a deal on this,
some things are not going to be paid.
You're not going to see
a government shutdown
like we saw back in 2011,
but you could see some folks
not getting money that's expected.
Some agencies not getting
money that's expected.
Congress is scheduled to be out
for a state work period starting May 29th.
So it may be if there's
no deal today or tomorrow,
that because of the way the
Senate and the House work,
that they may not even be able to get,
even if they agree to something,
something passed before
that June 1st deadline.
And that could mean that
some things don't get paid.
Congress is supposed to be
out from May 29th to June 5th.
So that whole week that's both the House
and the Senate are supposed to be out.
They're scheduled to be out.
Obviously, they could just not
take their state work period,
and stay in Congress and
get a deal hammered out.
June 15th is important,
because that's when you get
quarterly tax payments due.
A lot of that money from corporations,
and some money from individual
tax payers, businesses,
business owners things
like that pay quarterly.
So they'll get some more money.
Expected to get a good
a good chunk of change.
So the treasury has to sort
of just make things happen
between June 1st and June 15th
when they'll get some
more money rolling in.
On June 30th the treasury
is allowed too extract
about $140 billion in borrowing power
from a key federal retirement fund.
So there's still money coming in.
There's still going to be money coming in,
but there's a lot of money going out,
and no one quite knows how much it is.
But we do know that we've got
less than expected from taxes
and less than expected from some
of those payments that
were expected to come in.
Really we are only likely
to reach a default,
as in the U.S. doesn't
pay its debt obligations,
in August or September
because of all those
influxes and outflows of money.
Before we get to August or September,
there is money for things to be paid,
but there is not enough money.
And no one knows exactly
how much money there is.
Once we hit October,
an actual default of
multiple debt obligations
become very likely.
But again, we are in May right now.
You've still got June.
You've still got July.
You've still got August.
You've still got September
before it is likely the U.S.
just absolutely defaults on its bonds.
However, the market is already responding,
and we're not seeing much of a
response in the stock market.
And I'm going to show you
right now really quickly.
I want to put this up on your screen
what we're seeing in the market right now.
What you're seeing up there
on your screen is the NASDAQ,
and we have really seen the NASDAQ pickup.
This chart you're seeing here
is the year-to-date
response of the NASDAQ,
and you can see we're
really starting to pick up.
Stocks have really started to increase,
and you're seeing prices rise,
which shows you investors
on the stock side
really not that worried.
But where we are seeing some worry
is in the U.S. Treasury market,
and not on these long-dated bonds.
You're seeing here there is some worries
about the Debt Ceiling
deal not coming through,
but if you look at the
30-year, pretty muted.
You're seeing a one basis point move
on the 10-year note, the
most actively traded,
but look down here on this one month note.
Boom, look at that.
Just a huge pickup.
And that's because if there's no deal,
the idea is that that June
treasury bond might not be paid
or that June treasury
bill may not get paid.
And you are seeing folks sell
that off up 15 basis points.
We know when yields rise, prices fall.
That means people are selling.
They don't want it.
They're trying to get out of
that one month treasury bill,
and you are seeing a
significant market reaction.
I want to show you that year-to-date,
and you really just see it pick up here,
and you've seen that since
about late April, early May.
Just a significant increase in the value
or the yield on that
one month treasury bill.
So that just illustrating
how the market is responding
to this Debt Ceiling debate,
and we are seeing a
significant market response.
So let's take a step back
from this Debt Ceiling thing,
because I know you probably
heard all about that.
I just wanted to inject a
little reality in there.
The housing market
reports that we have seen
last month's existing
home sales report showed
the largest annual price
decline in 11 years.
However, that was mostly in the expensive
over $500,000 houses.
Houses below $500,000,
which is most houses on the
existing home sales market,
still seeing a lot of demand,
still seeing prices rise.
Want to throw another chart
up here on your screen,
and this is the New Home Sales report.
And now what we're seeing there
is an increase in the
number of new homes sold.
Last month we saw the
March report come in,
and that was the highest
number of new homes sold
in a month in about a year
going back to April of 2022.
Now it looks like that
September number is close,
but it's not.
You've seen actually the
number of homes sold,
of new homes sold in...
I'm sorry, the number of
new homes sold in April
was the highest since April of last year.
So really a big increase
in new homes sold.
And that chart illustrates there
the pickup we have seen in new homes sold.
Will that continue?
That's a big question that the
Fed is going to want to know.
That markets are going to want to know.
And we are seeing an increase in supply,
but we're not seeing prices falling.
And, in fact, new home
sales the median price
was almost $450,000 up
from $438,000 last month.
So this week's New Home
Sales report out on Tuesday
will be very watched
and very well followed.
You'll want to check that out.
We also get the Pending Home
Sales report on Thursday.
That's going to be the
latest detail on that.
One chart I want to throw
up here on your screen
as well is this chart
showing mortgage rates.
And I want you to contrast what we've seen
over the course of this
year with mortgage rates,
which have really risen a little bit,
gone down a little bit,
but they're largely right
where they were at the
beginning of the year
to that chart you saw with new home sales.
New home sales have
picked up significantly,
even though mortgage
rates have not declined,
even though they're still
around that high level
that we saw in November of last year.
This charge just illustrates
that even though mortgage rates
have not declined very significantly,
we have seen a defined and
clear pickup in new home sales.
That really just showing you
that the housing market
could be coming back,
and that'll be important
for the Federal Reserve.
Last thing, we want to talk about
Business Conditions report.
We get a number of reports out this week.
We've already got
the U.S. Services and
Manufacturing reports.
Those come out in Tuesday.
Those are for May, and
that's the latest update
on business conditions in the U.S.
You'll want to watch those,
because conditions have been deteriorating
through a lot of surveys.
We get the Richmond Fed Survey on Tuesday.
We get minutes from the Federal Reserve's
last policy meeting on Wednesday.
That's going to tell us a lot,
and that could be market moving.
We'll also get the Chicago
Fed National Activity Index
on Thursday, the Kansas
City Fed Survey on Thursday,
and the Advanced Economic
Indicators report on Friday.
That's going to tell us a lot
about the state of the economy,
and you'll want to watch that.
Listen that's going to do it
for us here on "Market Takes".
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin,
reporter at "The Wall Street Journal".
Thank you so much for being with us,
and I hope you'll be
with us again next time.